fast 500 milliarden euro umfasst der
bundeshaushalt 2021 über den wir ja seit
gestern sprechen nach einer
neuverschuldung im jahre 2020 von 218
milliarden euro auf 2.021 wir haben wir
noch 2021 neue schulden in höhe von fast
180 milliarden euro veranschlagt eine
entscheidung über die aufnahme von
schulden in dieser größenordnung ist
alles andere als leicht das fühlt und
spürt jeder hier und wir hatten viele
jahre in denen wir nicht mehr über neue
schulden sprechen mussten sondern einen
ausgeglichenen haushalt haben und wir
müssen uns auch immer wieder
vergegenwärtigen was öffentliche
schulden bedeuten
es bedeutet natürlich die belastung
künftiger haushalte
das bedeutet die notwendigkeit das
zurückzuzahlen und es bedeutet
einschränkungen für künftige ausgaben
und für künftige generationen
aber das ist das was für uns wichtig ist
und dafür bin ich sehr dankbar dass die
mehrheit dieses hauses das genauso sieht
wir leben in einer pandemie wir leben
damit in einer ausnahmesituation
wir leben mit einer herausforderung für
sie die bundesrepublik deutschland noch
nicht in dieser art gekannt hat und wir
müssen etwas dafür tun dass wir in
dieser besonderen situation auch
besonders handeln und das drückt dieser
uhrzeit aus
was uns leitet dabei dass deutschland
ein starkes land ist die viertgrößte
weltweit volkswirtschaft der welt ein
wichtiger partner in der europäischen
nationen der nato bei den vereinten
nationen ein weltweit anerkanntes freies
offenes demokratisches land und der land
mit gesellschaftlichem zusammenhalt und
einer starken zivilgesellschaft und
diese stärke das ist das was uns leitet
mit diesem haushalt
die wollen wir auch in dieser
ausnahmesituation erhalten und die
voraussetzungen dafür schaffen dass wir
nach überwindung der pandemie da wieder
anknüpfen können und diese rolle auch
weiterspielen können das ist das
auskunftsrecht
das macht ja niemand für uns dass wir
das heute waren und früher waren und
heute sind das reicht ja nicht aus
sondern wir müssen dafür arbeiten dass
das auch für die zukunft gesichert ist
und ich habe es schon mehrfach hier
gesagt diese pandemie ist ja etwas was
die kräfteverhältnisse auf der welt
durchaus erst einmal ökonomisch aber
vielleicht auch gesellschaftspolitisch
neu ordnen das heißt wir müssen da
schauen wie wir eingebettet sind in die
globalen zusammenhängen und 290
wirtschaftsprognosen des internationalen
währungsfonds jetzt anschauen dann sehen
wir dass viele länder sehr sehr starke
wirtschaftseinbrüche haben schon nach
den heutigen prognosen die sich ja immer
wieder erinnern können
das ist darunter auch viele europäische
länder italien frankreich großbritannien
alle um die minus zehn prozent für
dieses jahr gibt es eine mittelgruppe
usa deutschland gehört im raum blick mit
den prognosen dazu australien gelegen so
bei 4 bis 5 6% wirtschaftseinbruch und
dann gibt es länder wie zum beispiel
china die aus diesem jahr mit einem plus
von 1,9 prozent herauskommen werden
immer bei dem kampf gegen das gleiche
virus und das heißt wir müssen also
alles tun damit der weg der erholung auf
denen wir gekommen sind im dritten
quartal nach einem massiven einbruch im
zweiten quartal auch fortgesetzt werden
kann und wir müssen alles dafür tun dass
die prognosen dass wir 2022 wieder das
vorkrisenniveau erreichen können auch
wirklich realität werden und das was wir
immer beachten müssen ist das sich
weltweit zeigt die wirtschaft ist genau
dort vor allem widerstand
wo die pandemie unter kontrolle ist
es geht eben nicht um kampf für die
gesundheit gegen kampf für wirtschaft
und bildung und kultur und anderes
sondern beides miteinander in einklang
zu bringen das ist die komplizierte
aufgabe die wir auch täglich neu
austarieren müssen wir wissen zwar immer
mehr über das virus aber wir wissen
nicht alles zb auch nicht wie wir jetzt
im winter natürlich reagieren dass das
heißt also wir müssen sehen dass
deutschland zu denjenigen ländern zählt
diese zeit erfolgreich bewältigen
und ich bin der meinung der
bundeshaushalt schafft damit die
richtigen voraussetzungen deshalb danke
auch an die haushälter hier diesmal an
die haushälter die ja diesmal irgendwie
etwas mehr zu tun hatten nach der
regierungsvorlage um das dann in ein
gesetzeswerk jetzt zu bringen als das in
normalen zeiten der fall ist und deshalb
ein ganz besonderer dank wir haben die
aufgabe die folgen der pandemie
abzufedern und damit den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt
so gut hat zusammenhalt so gut wie
möglich zu sichern und wir müssen
belastbare grundlagen schaffen für
nachhaltiges wirtschaftswachstum in der
zukunft und deshalb haben wir auch
rekordinvestitionen in den haushalten
2020 121 und ich habe sehr wohl gestern
die debatte gehört dass man sagt so
regierung jetzt habt ihr das geld nun
gibt es aber bitte auch aus das nehmen
wir sehr ernst und ich sage ganz offen
manche stellen müssen wir sicherlich
auch etwas schneller handeln auch
manchmal in den absprachen mit den
ländern schneller handeln
das geld ist da und jetzt muss es
eingesetzt werden denn von der planung
im haushalt
es steht noch kein wirtschaftswachstum
sondern nur wenn das geld auch fließt
aber wir investieren klug in die zukunft
und so ist es zum beispiel richtig dass
wir 750 millionen euro für impfstoff
forschung und entwicklung ausgeben wir
können ja auch alle miteinander stolz
sein dass wir zwei firmen in deutschland
haben die eine die jetzt schon in der
zulassungsphase ist biontech mit pfizer
zusammen und fuhr weg die auf der
gleichen basis einen impfstoff
entwickeln
wir geben 9 milliarden in den nächsten
jahren für eine nationale wasserstoff
strategie aus zwei milliarden für
künstliche intelligenz 2 milliarden für
quantentechnologie 2 milliarden für
zukünftige kommen zehn
kommunikationstechnologien fünf und
sechs aber das geld muss eingesetzt
werden und da hinkommen wo es gebraucht
wird
deutsche unternehmen sollen im
internationalen wettbewerb mithalten
aber mir ist natürlich bewusst dass
viele unternehmen arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer in der korona situation
tiefe einschnitte hinnehmen müssen
und da denke ich natürlich wie viele
andere hier auch als erstes daran wie
viele menschen das betrifft in ihrer
persönlichen lebensgestaltung
wir hatten im november 2020 2,7
millionen arbeitslose das sind 519000
mehr als im november 2009 10 das sind
519000 familien die heute sorge haben
riesige sorge haben andere am sorge um
ihren arbeitsplatz und deshalb war es
natürlich als erstes richtig das
kurzarbeitergeld einzusetzen dieses
kurzarbeitergeld ist für viele viele
eine brücke und auch gerade bei den
einschränkungen die wir jetzt im
november/dezember vornehmen müssen haben
wir wieder 507
30.000 neue anmeldungen allein im
november gehabt und das zeigt diese
brücke funktioniert und sie muss deshalb
auch fortgesetzt werden
dafür haben wir die richtigen
rahmenbedingungen getroffen es geht
darum auch schnell den betroffenen zu
helfen auch darüber gesprochen worden
das sind gigantische summen von anträgen
natürlich die behandelt werden müssen
und vielen geht es zu langsam aber ich
weiß dass hier die regierungs der hart
arbeitet und ich bin sehr froh dass die
abschlagszahlungen jetzt auf 50.000 euro
erhöht werden konnten so dass da die
hilfe auch besser ankommt und meine
damen und herren es war uns schwere und
schmerzhafte entscheidung die wir bisher
schon treffen mussten mit den
einschränkungen im november die wir dann
am 2.12 noch einmal verlängert haben
aber das war absolut notwendig wir
müssen jetzt alles daran setzen dass wir
die deutsche stärke nicht nur im
wirtschaftlichen bereich erhalten
es geht nicht nur um ökonomische daten
sondern es geht eben auch um einen
weltweiten system wettbewerb den wir
spüren um unterschiedliche politische
und gesellschaftliche systeme und unser
handeln ist anders als das handelt in
ländern die stärke einer diktatur
gleichen das ist vollkommen klar
und deshalb wird die wahrnehmung von uns
natürlich auch mit der frage bestimmt
wie seid ihr denn durch diese
schwierigen monate gekommen und wir
werden anerkannt als freiheit diese
demokratie mit offener und stark
individualisierte gesellschaft darauf
sind wir stolz
deshalb ist der wichtigste schlüssel
wichtigste schlüssel den wir haben das
sind nicht die verbote und schließungen
und kontrollen die müssen an vielen
stellen seien aber der wichtigste
schlüssel zur erfolgreichen bekämpfung
des virus bei uns ist das
verantwortliche verhalten jedes
einzelnen und die bereitschaft zum
mitmachen und wir wissen wir wissen dass
wir verbindliche regeln brauchen und wir
wissen auch dass sich alle daran halten
aber meine liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die große mehrheit der
bevölkerung hat gezeigt dass sie bereit
ist rücksicht zu nehmen eigene
interessen zurückzustellen mitzuziehen
und ich bin davon überzeugt dass die
große mehrheit der bevölkerung dazu auch
weiter bereit ist weil sie die dinge so
sieht dass wir hier mit einer
außergewöhnlichen situation konfrontiert
werden und dafür bin ich von herzen
dankbar und das sollten wir alle
miteinander sein aber dieser dank doch
natürlich keine sonntagsrede sein
sondern im gegenzug erwarten die
bürgerinnen und bürger dass wir ihre
sorgen und ihre bedürfnisse auch ernst
nehmen in der gemeinschaft und das heißt
ganz konkret wir müssen jetzt bei der
verabschiedung dieses bundesanteils an
möglichst viele gruppen in der
gesellschaft denken die alle einschnitte
und rückschritte im zusammenhang mit
dieser pandemie hinnehmen müssen
und da das lassen sie mich mit den
älteren beginnen meine damen und herren
wir haben alle den älteren und den ganz
alten in unserem land viel zu verdanken
und das pandemie die manie macht das
leben in heimen und einrichtungen
einsamer wir haben oft darüber
gesprochen und die arbeitsbedingungen
für pflegekräfte sind noch belastender
als man sich das eigentlich wünschen
würde
wir haben 800.000 menschen in
deutschland die in pflegeeinrichtungen
leben aber wir haben auch millionen
menschen die ambulante pflege
in anspruch nehmen und wir haben viele
viele die durch familienangehörige
gepflegt werden
doch an die sollten wir denken ich habe
vor drei wochen gespräche mit
pflegebedürftigen und pflegekräften
geführt und ich habe gespürt unter welch
unglaublichen druck diese gerade die
pflegekräfte aber auch die zu pflegenden
stehen und die infektionen in den
alters- und pflegeheim nehmen des
sommers erregend zu und deshalb müssen
wir alles tun
wir haben dazu ja auch vorsorge
getroffen mit schnelltests die leider
nicht oft so schnell zur verfügung
stehen wie wir uns das wünschen würden
mit besserer ausstattung der pflegeheime
aber wir haben hier eine wirklich noch
große ausgabe aufgabe vor uns und der
hoffnungsschimmer den wir alle haben ist
dass die zügige impfung von
risikogruppen jetzt anfang des jahres
auch beginnen wird will an der stelle
allerdings sagen wir sollten hier sehr
realistisch an die dinge herangehen
wir werden im ersten quartal 2021 und
das ist noch mal das winterquartal noch
nicht so viele impfungen durchführen
können dass wir eine signifikante
veränderung sozusagen in der bevölkerung
sehen werden aber wir haben die chance
gerade die hochbetagte zu impfen
pflegekräfte zu impfen und damit da wir
im augenblick die meisten todesfälle
auftreten wirklich schon einen effekt zu
erreichen und da wäre viel gewonnen und
ich bin den ländern auch sehr dankbar
für die vorbereitung der impfzentren und
die vorbereitenden arbeiten und
natürlich auch dem
bundesgesundheitsminister meine damen
und herren neben den älteren müssen wir
natürlich auch auf die jüngeren achten
wir haben jetzt lehrer aus der im
frühjahr gesagt wir werden alles tun was
in unserer macht steht um kitas und
schulen offen zu halten
wir werden alles tun und kitas und
schulen offen zu halten allerdings
gehört in den wintermonaten
auch das lüften dazu das ist einfach so
weil wir besondere bedingungen haben
denn die panini hat manche defizite
offengelegt an deren überwindung wir
jetzt arbeiten wenn ich an die
digitalisierung denke und auch da ist es
so von der entscheidung dass zum
beispiel jeder lehrer in laptop bekommt
bis zu der umsetzung dass jeder ein
lehrer ein laptop in der hand hält
dauert es in deutschland immer monate
wir können an allen stellen schneller
werden aber genügend geld ist da wir
werden das nächste jahr zu einer
bildungsoffensive im digitalen bereich
nutzen die entwickelt werden werden
kompetenzzentren mit den ländern
entwickeln für digitale bildung wir
werden eine digitale bildungsplattform
schaffen und zwar nicht nur für schulen
sondern auch für berufsschulen und für
andere bildungsbereichen und meine damen
und herren wir müssen auf die familie
nach die familien stehen unter einem
besonderen stress unter einer besonderen
herausforderung in diesen zeiten und da
war es absolut richtig dass wir den
anspruch auf jeweils 15 in der
krankentage pro kind pro jahr
beschlossen haben für jedes elternteil
und für alleinerziehende 30 tage weil
jeder ahnt was jetzt los ist in den
familien wenn man morgens nicht weiß hat
das kind schnupfen ist kann es in die
schule geben was ist in der schule los
etwas wartet auf uns dieser stress gehen
müssen wir uns wirklich immer wieder vor
augen halten der jetzt gerade in der
kalten jahreszeit aus aber ich glaube
wir haben für familien vieles getan was
ich in diesem haus haushalt auch
widerspiegelt wir werden das kindergeld
erhöhen wir werden den entlastungsbetrag
für alleinerziehende verdoppeln der weg
der solidaritätszuschlag feldweg ab
ersten januar das sind spielräume für
familien die absolut wichtig sind und
deshalb ist dieser schwerpunkt im
haushalt von großer bedeutung
meine damen und herren
die familie das ist ja nichts was sich
auf deutschland beschränkt sondern wir
sind eingebettet als mitglied in der
europäischen union in die gesamte
herausforderung und deutschland stärke
ist ja gerade auch die verankerung in
starken europäischen und internationalen
partnerschaften und deshalb hat uns das
natürlich auch in unserer eu
ratspräsidentschaft beschäftigt wir alle
hatten uns diese ratspräsidentschaft
wirklich anders vorgestellt und vieles
ist dabei nicht umgesetzt konnte nicht
umgesetzt werden
das ist schade und das bestimmende thema
war natürlich die pandemie und deshalb
kann ich sagen dass wir hier in den
letzten monaten besser geworden sind was
die koordinierung anbelangt wir haben
jetzt mehrere video schalten gehabt mit
allen staats und regierungschefs für uns
immer wieder koordiniert haben ich will
nur daran will daran erinnern dass
unsere betrachtung der institute sind
zum beispiel von 50 als zielmarke
inzwischen in europa weitestgehend
akzeptiert wird auch von der cdc der
europäischen gesundheitsbehörde dass wir
mehr harmonisierung wenn auch noch keine
vollständige bei quarantäne regelung
haben dass es uns jetzt in der zweiten
welle weitestgehend gelungen ist den
freien warenverkehr doch eher offen
aufrecht zu erhalten das hat uns ja in
der ersten welle der epidemie sehr
geschadet
und es ist eine gute sache dass zusammen
mit mitgliedstaaten die europäische
kommission auch die impfstoffe beschafft
hat für uns ist das manchmal gar nicht
so ersichtlich dass das so wichtig ist
aber für die vielen kleineren
europäischen ländern ist das ganz ganz
wichtig dass wir nicht 27 mal die
vertragsverhandlungen mit jedem
impfstoffhersteller führen sondern dass
wir hier zu einer fairen verteilung
kommen dass wir sechs partnern mit sechs
unternehmen bereits solche verträge
abgeschlossen haben und dass auch keine
neiddiskussion zumindest innerhalb der
europäischen union aufkommen wird
bezüglich der verfügbarkeit dieser
impfstoffe
damit herren rocken wird der europäische
rat stattfinden
dieser europäische rat da würde ich
ihnen gerne mehr erzählen was wir dann
am ende freitag wirklich heraus gekommen
haben aber fast alles ist noch im fluss
wir werden natürlich über die frage des
austritt großbritanniens aus der
europäischen union und die vertraglichen
grundlagen darüber sprechen der
britische premierminister wird heute
abend bei der kommissionspräsidentin
seien die kommission führt für uns die
verhandlungen wir haben volles vertrauen
es gibt nach wie vor die chance eines
abkommens glaube nicht dass wir morgen
schon wissen ob das gelingt oder nicht
es kann jedenfalls nicht versprechen
aber wir arbeiten weiter daran aber wir
sind auch vorbereitet für bedingungen
die wir nicht akzeptieren können also
wenn es bedingungen gibt es von
britischer seite die wir nicht
akzeptieren können einen weg zu gehen
der ohne austritts abkommen das denn
eins ist klar es muss die integrität des
binnenmarktes gewahrt werden können und
da gibt es dann hätte es eine reihe
komplizierter fragen die vor allen
dingen darin liegen wie behandelt man
denn die dynamik des starten jetzt von
einem gleichen rechtssystem mehr oder
weniger harmonisierten rechtssystem und
über die jahre werden sich die
rechtssysteme natürlich im umweltrecht
im arbeitsrecht im gesundheitsrecht
überall auseinanderentwickelt und wie
reagieren jeweils die anderen seiten
darauf wenn sich die rechtssysteme und
die rechtssituation entweder
europäischen union oder großbritannien
ende und wir können nicht einfach sagen
darüber sprechen wir nicht sondern wir
müssen ein level playing field nicht nur
für heute kommen sollen wir müssen das
auch für morgen und übermorgen haben und
dafür muss man absprachen treffen wie
wir reagiert
man kann in der andere seine
rechtssituation verändert ansonsten
kommt es zu unfairen
wettbewerbsbedingungen die wir unseren
unternehmen nicht zumuten können das ist
die große schwierige frage die noch im
raum steht neben fragen der fisch quoten
und ähnlichem aber diese frage des
fairen wettbewerbs in sich auseinander
entwickeln den rechtssystemen die
eigentliche große frage auf die wir
betrieben befriedigende antworten
brauchen werden beim europäischen rat
über die beziehungen der europäischen
union zur türkei sprechen
leider ist das angebot was wir zu beginn
unserer präsidentschaft sehr intensiv
gemacht haben
mit der türkei in einen intensiven
dialog zu kommen nicht in dem maße
aufgegriffen worden wie ich mir das
gewünscht hätte
die aktivitäten im südlichen mittelmeer
sind nach wie vor da zypern hat
besonders darunter zu leiden
und so werden wir darüber entscheiden
müssen wie wir weiter vorgehen
und da liegt natürlich die aufgabe des
europäischen finanzrahmens und aufbau
fonds vor uns sie wissen dass es hier
schon im juli schwierige verhandlungen
das war damals schon absehbar dass die
geldsummen alleine nicht das problem
sind sondern auch die frage der
rechtsstaatlichkeit der konditionalität
eine große rolle gespielt hat sie hat
uns im juli schon sehr beschäftigt das
ganze musste jetzt ein recht umgesetzt
werden
ungarn und polen haben daraufhin gesagt
dass sie dem nicht zustimmen können und
wir suchen jetzt nach möglichkeiten und
der beibehaltung natürlich dieses
rechtsstaats mechanismus lösungen zu
finden um diese blockade aufzuheben auch
da kann ich ihnen leider noch nicht
sagen ob das gelingen wird oder nicht
die deutsche präsidentschaft arbeitet
sehr eng daran zusammen mit dem rad und
das ist wiederum liegt als problem vor
einer anderen eigentlich bestimmenden
frage für den morgigen europäischen rat
nämlich der frage wie verpflichtet sich
die europäische union zu ambitionierten
klimazielen am sonnabend finden
ist eine außerordentliche un konferenz
statt eigentlich haben wir alle gesagt
wir wollen im jahre 2020 unsere ziele
erhöhen und die europäische union steht
hier unter druck ich bin nur daran
erinnern china hat gesagt sie werden
2060 co2 frei sein
sie werden vor 2030 den peak bei den
co2-emissionen erreichen das sind sehr
ambitionierte vorhaben wir wissen dass
die vereinigten staaten von amerika nach
dem wechsel der administration
wahrscheinlich auch wieder oder nicht
wahrscheinlich zurückkehren werden zum
pariser abkommen das heißt es lasteten
große erwartungen auf europa unser
zehntes mindestens 55 prozent hier zu
vereinbaren für alle mitgliedsstaaten
die jeweiligen rechtlichen regelungen
werden dann ja erst 2021 erarbeitet ob
uns das gelingt hängt sehr stark auch
davon ab wie weit wir kommen bei den
finanziellen fragen und wir wissen jetzt
leider schon im blick auf die finanzen
für den haushalt 2021 dass wir nicht
pünktlich starten können mit der
mittelfristigen finanziellen vorausschau
und dass die ausgangssituation jetzt
natürlich wenn wir keinen haushalt haben
bedeutet ein zwölftel des vergangenen
haushaltes der aber geringer ist als der
haushalt war weil großbritannien jetzt
ausgetreten ist
das heißt das bedeutet für viele
programme die auch hier in deutschland
eine große rolle spielen die
sozialprogramme die koalitions programme
natürlich das erstmal sehr große
unsicherheit sein wird und deshalb
müssen wir uns da auf eine schwierige
zeit einstellen meine damen und herren
die notwendigkeit international
zusammenzuarbeiten hat sich während der
pandemie ja noch einmal wirklich
verstärkt wir sehen ist und ein beispiel
wo der wert globaler partnerschaften uns
nochmal richtig vor augen geführt wurde
das ist sicherlich die entwicklung
wirksamer impfstoffe und hier auch einer
fairen verteilung und deshalb bin ich
sehr dankbar dass wir in den g20 staaten
schon im märz vereinbaren konnten dass
wir eine globale in
native für die faire verteilung von
impfstoffen starten konnten ihn so zu
den sogenannten arts et axxelerate mit
der plattform kovacs und wir werden
jetzt darauf achten dass hier auch
wirklich genügend geld ist ist es noch
nicht genügend geld da deutschland hat
sich allerdings hier stark beteiligt
damit eben auch impfstoffe beschafft
werden können nicht nur für europa nicht
nur für großbritannien nicht nur für die
vereinigten staaten von amerika sondern
genauso für die entwicklungsländer als
präsident liebe kolleginnen kollegen der
erleben das spüren wir alle ganz
besondere wochen
wir sind in einer entscheidenden
vielleicht in der entscheidenden phase
der pandemie bekämpfung und alle
historischen erfahrungen lernen dass
gerade die zweite welle einer pandemie
die weitaus anspruchsvollere ist als die
erste
und sie lernen auch dass eine solche
zweite welle sehr schmerzhaft sein kann
und deshalb einen denken wäre ja auch an
die menschen die tag für tag an oder mit
dem virus sterben und dann wir denken an
die die zu dieser stunde in den
krankenhäusern um ihr leben kämpfen an
die die alles für sie geben die ärzte
und pfleger mit ich sage ihnen ganz
offen das kommt mir in diesen tagen
manchmal etwas zu kurz was sich da
abspielt was da geleistet
darauf sehen wir dass die zweite welle
dieser pandemie ist in sich hat und das
zeigen eben diesen erfahrungen auch so
und das ist jetzt nicht anders als es
früher war
und wir erleben sie aber ja so etwas wie
ein wechselbad der gefühle auf der einen
seite finde ich können wir durchaus
stolz darauf sein wozu wir in den
letzten zehn monaten seit beginn der
pandemie in der lage waren
jeder und jede einzelne von uns aber
auch als gemeinschaft und wir haben
schon ein sehr großes stück des weges
zurückgelegt wir hatten uns am anfang
des jahres mit einem ganz unbekannten
virus zu tun wir wissen heute sehr viel
mehr über die wege der infektion über
die möglichkeiten sich zu schützen über
symptome und behandlungspflege wir
konnten zu beginn des jahres niemandem
sagen die schnelles gelingen würde einen
impfstoff zu entwickeln und das heute in
deutschland an vielen orten impfzentren
errichtet werden und zwar mit der
begründeten hoffnung dass er dafür auch
ein impfstoff da ist das ist etwas was
es in der geschichte der menschheit noch
nicht gegeben hat in einer so kurzen
zeit das müssen wir uns vor augen führen
also wir sehen licht am ende des tunnels
und warum ist das so das ist so weil wir
menschen kreativ sünde bei einen
unglaublichen forschergeist haben weil
weltweit die besten wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler uns gezeigt haben
was im menschen steckt und ich bin
überzeugt wenn diese pandemie überhaupt
irgendetwas gutes hat dann ist es zeigt
sie uns wozu wir menschen imstande sind
wenn wir unser herz in die hand nehmen
und wenn wir mit ausdauer kreativität
handeln und wenn wir über grenzen hinweg
zusammenarbeiten aber
aber diese kolleginnen und kollegen
ich habe eben von einem wechselbad der
gefühle gesprochen
und das heißt dass zu dem gesamten bild
auf der anderen seite eben leider auch
gehört dass die seit dem 2
november gelten in kontakt
beschränkungen zwar das dramatische
exponentielle wachstum der
neuinfektionen der wochen stoppen
konnten
aber die trendumkehr ausgeblieben ist
die fall zahlen liegen auf einem viel zu
hohen niveau und ganz alarmierend ist
wird die sehr die zahl der menschen
wächst die intensivmedizinisch behandelt
werden müssen und die menschen die an
die zahl der menschen die an dem virus
sterben und die will sommer vor augen
führen
die erste lesung des haushalts hat am
dienstag wurde da wurde er eingebracht
im 29 september eingebracht
daten der 1827 fälle an einem tag 352
belegte intensivbetten und zwölf tote
heute haben wir 20 1815 tel
3500 mehr als vor einer woche
4257 belegte intensivbetten gegen
gestern zwei von heute ist noch nicht da
und 590 tote und die konklusion heißt
einfach die zahl der kontakte ist zu
hoch die reduktion der kontakte ist
nicht ausblenden und
und meine damen und herren ich glaube
ich glaube ganz einfach und das ist
jetzt ja wissen sie das ist der
unterschied das ist ja auch nicht so
schlimm es ist schade aber es nicht so
schlimm ich glaube an die kraft der auch
hier das europa heißt es dort steht so
steht hat es der aufklärung zu verdanken
und den glauben daran dass es
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse gibt die
real sind und an die man sich besser
halten sollte und die kinder ganz sicher
die heutige zum physikstudium
entschieden das hätte ich in der alten
bundesrepublik wahrscheinlich nicht
getan weil ich ganz sicher war dass man
vieles außer kraft setzen kann
aber die schwerkraft nicht die
lichtgeschwindigkeit nicht und andere
fakten nicht und das wird auch weiter
gelten
und weil die zahl so sind diese sind
müssen wir etwas tun und zwar bund und
länder gemeinsam
ich kenne die zuständigkeiten der länder
im infektionsschutzgesetz wir haben ja
hier auch viel darüber gesprochen und
ich achte diese zuständigkeiten auch und
ich weiß aus den vielen runden die wir
miteinander hatten wir können es nur
gemeinsam machen aber ich kenne
natürlich auch meine besondere
verantwortung auch die verantwortung der
bundesregierung und deshalb halte ich
schon für geboten dass sie wissen was
mich leitet und da will ich sagen dass
ich glaube dass wir gut daran tun das
was uns die wissenschaft sagt nämlich
gestern die leopoldina auch wirklich
ernst zu nehmen wir freuen uns sehr
freuen
denn die es geschafft ein impfstoff
entwickelt wir freuen uns wenn wir einen
menschen haben sie bei uns den pcr test
entwickelt haben
und wenn die wissenschaftler uns dann
etwas sagen dann fangen wir an zu sagen
denn ja könnte sein und kann auch nicht
sein ich kann das so sagen nehmen wir
das ernst die leopoldina hat ins gestern
die leopoldina hat uns gestern in drei
stufen gesenkt was jetzt notwendig ist
und da gibt es eine entwicklung über die
ich mich sehr freue
das sozusagen die stufe 2 was tun wir ab
dem 24 12
doch weit gehen zu sagen und strittiger
zu werden scheint dass wir danach eine
phase brauchen vielleicht bis zum 10
januar wir dürfen nicht vergessen das
ziel heißt runter auf 50 fälle pro
100000 in sieben tagen lässt ihn heißt
nicht nach tagen zu rechnen sondern nach
resultat zu rechnen sonst entgleitet und
die pandemie wieder und wieder das
können wir auch den menschen nicht
zumuten sie immer wieder darüber runkel
aufzulaufen das ist ganz klar
und deshalb sind die erzählungen meiner
meinung nach richtig geschäfte dann zu
schließen
die zahl der menschen die sich treffen
zu klein wie möglich zu halten
wir haben regelungen getroffen dass
weihnachten und familienfeste möglich
sein soll aber ich appelliere an jedem
wirklich hier vorsichtig zu sein und ich
sage es auch nochmal ich habe schon
öffentlich gesagt sagte auch ihr normal
ich halte die öffnung von hotels für die
übernachtung von verwandten für falsch
weil sie wieder anreize schafft die
vielleicht nicht notwendig sind aber das
ist jetzt mal etwas was wir nicht mehr
überwinden werden
ich will halte es auch für richtig die
schulen in dieser zeit entweder durch
verlängerung der ferien zu schließen bis
zum 10
januar oder aber digital unterricht zu
machen oder was auch immer dass es egal
wir brauchen aber kontakt reduzierungen
und ich sage ihnen was mir jetzt so
gemacht und darüber müssen wir in den
nächsten tagen sehr schnell sprechen das
ist die entwicklung im augenblick 3500
fälle mehr als vor einer woche ich weiß
dass wir bundesländer haben die sachsen
thüringen brandenburg sachsen anhalt in
denen wäre ziemlich freien anstieg der
zeller
aber selbst wenn wir die rausrechnen
haben wir immer noch anstiege und bis
weihnachten sind es noch 14 tage genau
14 tagen
und wir müssen alles tun dass wir nicht
wieder ein exponentielles wachstum und
nun hat es die leopoldina für diese zeit
gesagt wir sollen alle kontakte die
nicht absolut notwendig sind wirklich
reduzieren und mein und so hart das ist
und ich weiß wie viel liebe dahinter
steckt wenn glühweinstände aufgebaut
werden den wasserbecken aufgebaut werden
es verträgt sich nicht mit der mit dem
vereinbarung dass wir zum beispiel essen
und verzehren nur zum mitnehmen nach
hause wirklich veränderungen
es tut mir leid aber es tut mir wirklich
im
herzen aber wenn wir dafür den preis
zahlen dass ihr todeszahl von tag am tag
590 menschen haben dann ist das nicht
akzeptabel aus meiner sicht deshalb
müssen wir das wissen
geradezu anfleht vor weihnachten bevor
man oma und opa großeltern und ältere
menschen sieht eine woche der kontakt
reduzierung zu ermöglichen dann sollten
wir vielleicht doch noch mal nachdenken
ob der nicht irgendein weg finden die
ferien nicht erst am 19
beginnt zu lassen sondern vielleicht
schon am 16 was wird man dann im
rückblick auf ein jahrhundertereignis
mal sagen wenn wir nicht in der lage
waren für diese drei tage noch
irgendeine lösung zu finden
und das mag ja sein dass man hier sein
dass die aufhebung der schmutzig das
falsche ist dann muss es der digital
unterricht oder sonstwas zeit
ich weiß es nicht das ist auch nicht
meine kompetenz da will ich mich nicht
einmischen
ich will nur sagen wenn wir jetzt vor
weihnachten zu viele kontakte haben und
anschließend ist das letzte weihnacht
mit den großeltern war dann werden wir
etwas versäumt haben das sollten wir
nicht tun
und die leopoldina hat auch recht wenn
sie uns mahnt dann nach der zeit des
zurück fans die möglichst höchste
berechenbarkeit für die weiteren
maßnahmen dann auch aufzuzeigen
ich meine wenn wir ganz realistisch sind
dann müsste die winterzeit geht bis
mitte märz
das ist eine überschaubare zeit von
anfang januar bis mitte märz die kriegen
den wir werden dann nach menschlichem
ermessen einen impfstoff haben dann wird
sich das von monat zu monat verbessern
und wir müssen jetzt unsere einmal
anstrengen die haben schon so viele
monate mit diesem virus verbracht und
sie haben doch gelernt wir können etwas
dagegen tun das ist ein bisschen
unmenschlich dass ich immer auf distanz
gehen muss dass ich kein treffen soll
und wenn dann nur mit schutzvorrichtung
das ist richtig und diesem monat schutz
aber das ist ja auch nicht etwas was
unser leben total zerstört und deshalb
sollten wir schauen dass wir nicht so
viele menschenleben zerstören und
gleichzeitig das wissen der damit auch
die wirtschaft am laufen halten und in
diesem sinne bitte ich sie auch die
nächsten nicht einfachen tage mit uns
gemeinsam durchzustehen herzlichen magen
geworden der bundeskanzlerin ihr der
heutigen debatte kritiker haben ihr sehr
schon sehr früh das credo der mutter der
nation über gehängt und in einem
positiven sinne hat sie dieses kriege
heute erfüllt sie hat nämlich erstmal
allen gedankt die gegen diese pandemie
kämpfen vor allen dingen auch den
menschen für ihre große geduld die große
mehrzahl der menschen die diese ganzen
einschränkungen mit macht damit dieser
virus in den griff gebracht werden kann
hat sie gesagt sie hat sich bedankt bei
den ärzten und pflegern und bei denen
die impfstoffe entwickeln und sie hat
sich bedankt bei den ländern und den
ministerpräsidenten für die
zusammenarbeit gleichzeitig war sie aber
auch die malerin am schluss und
natürlich die physikerin die in nämlich
gesagt hat physikalische
gesetzmäßigkeiten kann man nicht außer
kraft setzen